je vous propose de députer cette
commission des finances monsieur le
Président Monsieur le vice-président de
la commission des affaires étrangères de
la défense et des forces armées monsieur
le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir ce matin le premier président
Pierre Moscovici pour nous présenter la
vie du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques sur le projet de loi de
programmation militaire pour les années
2024 à 2030 depuis la révision de la
LOLF que nous avons adoptée fin 2021 le
Haut Conseil peut désormais en
application de son article 61 rendre un
avis sur les projets de loi de
programmation dites sectorielle il
s'agit donc là d'une première
application de cette nouvelle
disposition puisque les deux autres
textes de programmation récent la loi de
programmation pour la recherche et la
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur avait été
déposé avant l'entrée en vigueur de la
révision de c'est toutefois une première
un peu particulière puisque la LOLF
prévoit que c'est ta vie permette en
principe d'évaluer la compatibilité
entre le projet de loi d'une part et la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques en vigueur d'autres parts or
comme vous le savez la loi de
programmation des finances publiques en
vigueur nous n'en avons pas ce qui rend
l'exercice pour le moins complexe
l'enjeu budgétaire du projet de loi de
programmation militaire et de taille et
mérite qu'on s'y penche 400 milliards
d'euros de crédits nouveaux sont en
effet prévus sur la période portant les
crédits de la mission défense de 44
milliards d'euros en 2023 à 69 milliards
d'euros en 2030
[Musique]
très prochainement c'est pour nous
l'occasion d'un éclairage différent sur
la LPM que nous devons considérer dans
le contexte plus large du budget de
l'État l'exercice à ses limites nous en
avons conscience puisque l'examen du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques n'est pas parvenu à
son terme ça a été dit
pour réaliser les objectifs de la loi de
programmation militaire l'inflation en
effet introduit une incertitude majeure
elle représenterait 30 milliards d'euros
sur l'ensemble de la période selon une
estimation
modérée mais nous demande mais nous
demandons si cette évaluation n'est pas
sous-estimée là encore nous avons le
sentiment d'un certain manque de
transparence il est évidemment très
difficile d'évaluer ce que signifiera
vraiment la trajectoire qui nous est
proposée en termes réelles
est-ce que vous pourrez nous indiquer
quelles anticipation les hauts conseils
sur l'inflation sur la période concernée
le rapport d'une partie importante de
l'effort après 2027 n'arrange évidemment
rien sans doute pourrait vous aussi nous
éclairer sur l'évolution de la part du
budget de la défense dans le budget de
l'État la défense et le secteur régalien
par excellence les lois de programmation
garantissent certes des ressources à
certains secteurs au détriment d'autres
dépenses budgétaires mais les secteurs
régaliens ne sont-ils pas eux aussi en
train de devenir une variable
d'ajustement compte tenu de l'ensemble
de des dépenses contraintes le risque
que les dépenses d'investissement qui
courent sur de longues périodes soit en
particulier victime de ces ajustements
et bien connu la pratique d'étalement
des programmes a été ajuste titre très
critiqué par la Cour des comptes surtout
ces sujets monsieur le Président nous
vous écouterons avec grand intérêt je
vous cède la parole merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur le madame la
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs
sénateurs merci de m'avoir invité devant
vos deux commissions
en tant que certes pour une présidente
mais en l'occurrence en tant que
président du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques ce que je suis également
escalier afin de vous présenter les
principales conclusions de notre avis
relatif aux projets de loi de
programmation militaire pour les années
2024 à 2030 alors ma venue dans ce
contexte ce matin est une première
puisque c'est la première fois que le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques est
amené vous l'avez dit Madame présidente
d'exercer la nouvelle compétence que le
législateur organique lui a donné en
décembre 2021 qui consiste à rendre un
avis sur la compatibilité des lois de
programmation du sectorielle avec les
objectifs de dépenses de plus réelle que
l'État fixé en loi de programmation des
finances publiques et pour autant je
réponds tout de suite à votre
observation madame la Présidente et au
risque de décevoir mais nous n'y pouvons
rien le HCP n'est pas en mesure
aujourd'hui de rendre un avis tel que
prévu par le législateur organique en
effet le projet de loi de programmation
des finances publiques déposés au
Parlement septembre 2022 vous le savez
n'est pas été adopté et le HFP en
conséquence ne peut pas évaluer la
compatibilité du projet de loi de
programmation militaire avec une boîte
de programmation de finance publique qui
n'existe pas la loi organique prévoit à
défaut de loi de programmation des
finances publiques que le hcfp analyse
la compatibilité du projet de loi de
programmation militaire avec l'article
liminaire de la dernière loi de finance
mais nous avons un autre problème c'est
que celle-ci
porte exclusivement sur les 2023 alors
que le projet de loi de programmation
militaire commence en 2024 donc il n'y a
pas non plus cette porte d'entrée là
ainsi en l'absence de loi de
programmation de finances publiques le
hcfp ne peut pas exercer pleinement son
mandat déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
plusieurs fois dans la commission des
finances je le répète aujourd'hui
la nécessité pour la France de disposer
d'une loi de programmation des finances
publiques à même de fournir une encre
plus réelle pour l'évolution de la
dépense publique et de la dette est
impérative ça n'est pas une anecdote ce
n'est pas une bricole je pense que ça
pose toute une série de problèmes tant
juridique que politique le Parlement
adopté plusieurs lois de programmation
sectorielle ces dernières années en
particulier le mode programmation pour
la recherche 2021 2030 et la loi
d'orientation et les programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur 2023 2027 je ne
conteste en rien
l'intérêt de ses lois de programmation
au contraire c'est une démarche qui
peut-être utile tant il est nécessaire
pour nos politiques publiques d'être
prévisible et financé à moyen terme mais
je le dis avec un peu de force ceci ne
doit pas se faire dans le brouillard on
ne peut pas on ne doit pas empiler des
lois de programmation sans fixer de
limite globale à la dépense publique au
risque de s'engager sur une trajectoire
de finances publiques qui n'est pas
soutenable le Parlement et le
gouvernement ont besoin de fixer des
plafonds plus réels de dépenses
publiques comme le législateur organique
l'a prévu d'ailleurs il y a à peine plus
d'un an car cet outil est indispensable
pour piloter l'évolution des comptes
publics je rappelle ici que la France a
connu une érosion progressive de la
situation de ces finances publiques au
sein de la zone euro elle faisait plutôt
figure de bonne élève au moment de
l'entrée dans l'euro au début des années
2000 nous avions exactement la même
dette publique que l'Allemagne
58,9% de dettes dans le PIB et
progressivement nous sommes devenus un
des pays plus endettés de cette zone
monétaire l'Allemagne a pris 10 points
l'Italie a pris 40 points la France a
pris 55 points ça ce sont des chiffres
tout à fait objectif alors qu'un certain
nombre de nos partenaires frappaient par
les mêmes crises que nous on réussit à
engager entre ces crises une dynamique
de diminution de la dette c'est-à-dire
profiter des périodes de croissance pour
réduire les déficits il n'en a pas été
ainsi en France la loi de programmation
de finances publiques doit nous donner
cette boussole ça doit nous permettre
d'empêcher une dérive lente de nos
comptes publics en prévoyant des efforts
raisonnables car la France n'est pas une
championne de l'austérité c'est pas sa
culture ne l'a jamais fait et je doute
que elle s'y engage je ne crois pas
qu'elle le doivent mais des efforts
raisonnables de maîtrise la dépense
publique chaque année permettrait de
rester conforme aux objectifs fixés nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui le cadre
conceptuel et législatif pour le faire
les pouvoirs publics doivent utiliser
tous les moyens leur disposition à
commencer par ce prévu par l'organique
pour gérer au mieux les finances
publiques et pour maintenir une
gouvernance qui soit
irréprochable et donc je termine sur ce
point introductif mais qui pour moi
était important le conseil et c'est dit
dans notre avis appelle une nouvelle
fois à l'adoption rapide d'une boîte de
programmation des finances publiques qui
souhaitent à la fois crédible et
ambitieuse
un peu plus que le projet qui vous a été
soumis me semble-t-il je le dis au nom
d'un précédent avis du Haut Conseil qui
estimait qu'il fallait faire un effort
pour le désendettement qui soit un peu
plus conséquent et un peu plus rapide et
l'objectif ce serait de fournir l'encre
pluriannuel des finances publiques dont
la gestion de celle-ci a besoin en
l'absence de loi de programmation de
finance publique le ACFP a néanmoins
décidé comme le gouvernement lui a
demandé
d'examiner la trajectoire la conformité
de la trajectoire du projet de
programmation militaire avec le projet
de loi de programmation des finances
publiques déposer le 26 septembre 2022
au Parlement donc celui-ci qui n'existe
pas enfin le projet existe mais la loi
n'existe pas nous certes de référence
pour cet avis je tiens à souligner un
point important qui est que cette
trajectoire n'a pas été actualisée
depuis septembre 2022 alors même que la
loi finance initiale pour 2023 a été
votée avec un montant de dépenses accrue
de 8 milliards d'euros par rapport à
celle-ci dans le projet de programmation
de finances publiques et donc la
trajectoire de référence elle est d'ores
et déjà dépassée en 2023 au moins en
prévision nous le savons j'en viens
maintenant au contenu de la vie rendu
par le HCF le projet de loi de
programmation militaire prévoit une
trajectoire de crédit de paiement pour
la mission défense qui s'élève à 400
milliards d'euros au total sur la
période 2024-2030 en faisant la somme de
l'ensemble des exercices le projet de
loi prévoit une augmentation des crédits
de la mission défense de 3 milliards
d'euros par an entre 2024 et 2027 puis
de 4,3 milliards d'euros par an jusqu'en
2030 les crédits atteindraient ainsi 69
milliards d'euros courants en 2030
contre 47 en 2024
la vie du Haut Conseil porte trois
grands messages sur lesquels je vais
revenir maintenant 1 il nous semble que
la trajectoire de crédit de paiement de
400 milliards d'euros est compatible
avec celle du projet de programmation de
finance publique en revanche c'est le
deuxième message le Conseil ne peut pas
assurer que la trajectoire des besoins
programmés qui est-elle évaluée à
413,3 milliards d'euros par le projet de
loi de programmation militaire vous
m'avez posé la question monsieur le
Président soit entièrement prise en
compte dans le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques dès
lors
je vais utiliser un mot que vous avez
toute une gradation une sémantique dans
les avis du Haut Conseil la
compatibilité des deux trajectoires pour
nous affecter d'incertitude je le dis
monsieur le Président je n'aime pas
beaucoup évoqué là sa série je pense que
c'est suppose un vrai désir de tromper
et je pense qu'on la matière
vous êtes des responsables politiques il
faut toujours se garder de l'excès je
préfère le mot d'incertitude en
l'occurrence enfin troisième message le
lcfp souhaite attirer l'attention du
Parlement sur le fait que dans la mesure
où environ 20% des dépenses de l'État
sont désormais couvertes par des lois de
programmation
sectoriel qui vise des augmentations
importantes de moyens les dépenses qui
restent qui représentent dans 80% des
dépenses de l'État devront faire l'objet
d'une maîtrise encore plus stricte pour
permettre le respect de la trajectoire
visé par le projet finance publique
simple effet de vase communicant si vous
dépensez beaucoup sur 20% si vous avez
une contrainte globale vous allez devoir
économiser plus sur ce qui reste tout le
reste je vais y revenir premier message
donc
la trajectoire des crédits de paiement
de la mission défense est compatible
avec celle prévue dans le projet finance
publique de septembre 2022 je rappelle
que le projet de programmation des
finances publiques couvre la période
2023 2027 alors que le projet de loi de
programmation militaire s'étend de 2024
à 2030 vous avez soulevé cette question
l'examen de la compatibilité de
trajectoire député avec le projet de
programmation de finance publique ne
peut donc uniquement porter que sur la
période 2024 2027 bien sûr le reste
c'est pour prochaine loi de
programmation de finances publiques si
celle-ci finit par voir le jour le hcfp
a constaté que les crédits budgétaires
de la mission défense inscrit dans le
projet de programmation militaire et le
projet de loi de programme zone finance
publique sont identiques pour les années
2024 à 2000 et 2025 l'administration a
par ailleurs indiqué au HCP que la
trajectoire du proche de la
programmation était bien incluse dans
celle du projet loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années 2026
ce que le Conseil n'a pas pu vérifier
directement car le projet de
programmation de finance publique ne
présente les crédits des missions
budgétaires que si elle est trois
premières années de programmation enfin
nous n'avons pas de raison puisque les
marges prévues sont identiques d'en
douter donc nous estimons qu'il y a
compatibilité vous avez évoqué la
question des restes à payer de la
mission défense qui en 2022 représente
en effet 93 milliards d'euros qui sont
en hausse de 8 milliards par rapport à
2021 sont des rapports de charges comme
l'explique la note d'exécution
budgétaire 2021 de la mission défense
publiée par la Cour des comptes il reste
à payer augmente pour deux raisons
d'abord
des acquisitions importantes de matériel
une modification d'une partie des
contrats de maintenance la hausse des
investissements entraîne donc
mécaniquement une augmentation des
restes à payer la hausse des ressources
prévues par la loi programme solitaire
permettra de financer ces restes à payer
nous semble-t-il deuxième message le
Haut Conseil relève cependant que le
proche loi de programmation établit à
73,3 milliards d'euros donc plus de 400
milliards d'euros 413 le montant des
besoins programmés je mets des
guillemets pour la période 2024 2030
alors qu'il n'y identifie que 400
milliards d'euros de crédit budgétaire
pour les financiers il y a donc un
hiatus de 13,3 milliards d'euros il
ressort des échanges d'information du
hcfp que le gouvernement à travers
questionnaire et auditions que ces 13
milliards d'euros seraient financé de
trois manières d'abord l'administration
attend des ressources extra budgétaires
notamment des recettes de cession
immobilière des sessions de matériel
ainsi que les recettes du service de
santé des armées le total de ces
ressources extrabutaires s'élevant à
hauteur de 5,9 milliards d'euros sur la
période disons que sur les 13,3 c'est
5,9 peu d'estimer comme en gros
documenté le besoin supplémentaire
serait financé par solidarité
interministérielle ça n'est pas des
transferts provenant des autres budgets
ministériels ayant des dépenses moindres
que prévu enfin
les moindres dépenses habituellement
observées au sein du ministère de la
réponses que ce qu'on appelle les marges
frictionnelles ainsi que le report de
charge du ministère donc dont j'ai parlé
serait mobilisé pour assurer le besoin
de financement résiduel
ça c'est moins documenté
c'est 13,3 milliards d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires ne sont pas isolés dans
le loi de programmation de finances
publiques et le gouvernement n'a pas
fourni d'éléments permettant au conseil
de s'assurer que ces dépenses
supplémentaires sont pleinement prises
en compte dans la trajectoire de
dépenses du produit finances publiques
donc là dessus autant sur les 400
milliards on peut dire qu'il y a une
conformité parce que c'est ça notre
mission
pardonateur de la commission de la
défense les affaires étrangères nous
n'intervions pas sur le fond mais notre
travail c'est la compatibilité avec les
c'est un regard un peu différent qui
peut vous intéresser mais bon nous ne
sommes pas sur le fond donc la
compatibilité d'assurer pour les
casseurs moins assurés pour les 413
surtout pour la différence entre 13,3 et
5,9 là n'est pas documenté ainsi
l'impact exact du projet de
programmation militaire sur le montant
des bourses plus prévu dans le projet et
finance publique je reprends mon môme
monsieur le Président reste affecté
d'incertitude
je relève d'ailleurs que d'ores et déjà
le mystère des armées a indiqué demandé
pour 2023 des ouvertures de crédit
supplémentaires très significative
notamment en lien avec l'inflation qui
s'annonce plus forte que prévu par le
gouvernement plus fort jusqu'où je vais
pas m'engager là-dessus disons que nous
avons dans des avis précédents soulignés
que la prévision pour 2023 4,2 % était
en dessous du consensus qui est à 4,5
lequel pourrait lui-même évoluer un peu
c'est évidemment quelque chose que nous
devons suivre dans le temps et qu'il y
aura un impact sur l'ensemble de nos
finances publiques
nous n'avons pas là dessus de lumière
précise que les économistes qui
s'interrogent enfin on voit bien
l'inflation tout de même paraît un
risque plus important et plus prolongé
que ce que certains avaient pensé enfin
et c'est le dernier message de cet avis
le Conseil note que le projet de
programmation militaire conjointement le
droit de programmation déjà voté en
matière de recherche et de sécurité
intérieure donc il y a trois lois de
programmation sectoriale déjà voté
contraint fortement les autres dépenses
du budget de l'État et la maîtrise de la
dépense qui est à ce jour peu documentée
en effet les crédits couverts par ces
trois lois de programmation vont
connaître une croissance plus rapide que
le total la dépense de l'État ce sont
trois lois expansives disons
ce qui impose pour respecter l'objectif
de dépenses fixé en projet de
programmation de finances publiques
qui n'est déjà pas très ambitieux je dis
au passage mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs une croissance faible en
valeur et même une baisse en volume des
autres dépenses de l'État si on prend ce
chiffre au pied de la lettre le hcfp
estime ainsi que ces autres dépensent
donc les 80 %
orchent sécurité intérieure et
programmation militaire se ramener en
volume ABC de 1,4% en moyenne par an sur
la période 2023 2027 soit une baisse
plus forte que par le passé puisqu'elles
ont diminué de seulement 0,3% en moyenne
par an entre 2012 et 2019 le Haut
Conseil avait déjà indiqué dans son avis
de septembre 20012 sur l'homme
programmation de finances publiques que
celui-ci prévoyait une trajectoire en
réalité ambitieuse de maîtrise de la
dépense de l'État qui pourtant
n'aboutissait pas des objectifs
ambitieux en matière de déficit et de
dette vous voyez donc la complexité de
l'affaire et de surcroît que cette
maîtrise était peu documentée là on une
pression supplémentaire et une exigence
de documentation encore plus grande ces
calculs peuvent paraître très aride je
le conseille en même temps je crois
qu'ils sont pas très compliqué ils nous
mettent face à une réalité concrète nous
faisons face comme les autres pays
avancés à une montagne d'investissement
et de dépenses publiques indispensable
pour restaurer notre défense nos
hôpitaux nos universités pour réaliser
une transition énergétique écologique et
ni le conseil ni à Cour des comptes ne
le nid il y a besoin d'investir
massivement pour notre avenir et pour
notre croissance face à ses besoins face
à cette montagne d'investissement nous
avons un mur de dette qui est déjà très
élevé près de 3000 milliards nous sommes
à plus de sens pour cent de dette dans
le PIB à une dette qui désormais coûte
puisque les taux d'intérêt vous n'avez
pas interrogé là-dessus ne sont plus
négatifs ou bas ils sont solides et de
surcroît voilà tout ça dépend aussi de
la crédibilité du pays
nous n'avons pas par le passé utilisé
les périodes de retour la croissance je
lui dis pour réduire suffisamment le
déficit annuel aussi les financements
qu'il est prévu d'accorder à l'état
régalien ou à d'autres politiques
implique des efforts collectifs de
maîtrise d'autant plus importantes de la
dépense dans les autres champs de
l'action publique voilà une réalité sauf
accepter que tout dérape mais le
dérapage de tout a des conséquences
c'est l'explosion du service de la dette
et c'est l'incapacité à financer les
investissements vous voyez donc on est
devant une équation à la fois assez
simple et assez compliquée je répète il
n'y a aucune fatalité à ce que la France
continue à voir sa situation de finance
luxérodée je crois notre pays
parfaitement mesure de s'engager dans
une revue de ses dépenses publiques d'en
tirer les enseignements pour maîtriser
ce qui n'est pas efficace la refus de
dépenses publiques c'est pas un exercice
budgétaire
il s'agit pas de postuler je ne sais
quelle réduction il s'agit de voir à
travers la qualité de la dépense
publique comment on peut modifier les
politiques publiques les améliorer et en
dégager des ressources supplémentaires
la Cour des comptes que je préside
également et bien sûr prête à s'y
impliquer je lui dis et nous allons
contribuer les citer à la revue de la
qualité de la dépense la réflexion sur
cette mission de l'État par des notes
thématiques nous produirons 9 notes
thématiques ici au mois de juin juillet
qui seront des analyses de politiques
publiques au fond justement sur les
autres dépenses de l'État nous espérons
que je travaille sera utile au Parlement
sans l'implication duquel rien ne sera
possible voilà madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs les quelques
réflexions liminaires que je
souhaiterais partager avec vous au sujet
de ce projet de programmation militaire
je vous remercie de votre attention et
je me tiens à vos dispositions avec
l'équipe qui m'entoure plutôt qui ne
m'entoure pas mais qui est là pour
répondre à vos questions l'équipe de
haut conseil et finances publiques qui
est limitée en quantité mais
exceptionnelle en qualité tout est
possible en matière de dépenses
publiques
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
présidents je vais maintenant passer la
parole
à Dominique dellège notre rapporteur
pour avis puis à Jean-François Husson
notre rapporteur général et puis
également celles et ceux d'entre vous
qui souhaiteraient prendre la parole je
précise toutefois pour l'ensemble des
personnes ici présentes qu'à 10h15 la
commission des affaires étrangères la
défense et des forces armées à un autre
engagement voilà
Dominique dellège la parole est à vous
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le président
vous vous avez invité à réfléchir sur le
terme
d'insincérité d'incertitude
j'ai envie de dire qu'à ce stade nous
avons après vous avoir entendu quelques
certitudes c'est que c'est toi de
programmation militaire ne va pas être
un long fleuve tranquille
deuxième point je voudrais soulever
c'est la totale
concordance de vue que pour ma part j'ai
avec la commission de la Défense dans
les propos de Cédric Perrin
je voudrais soulever quatre points très
très rapidement
le premier vous avez parlé des
ressources budgétaires les 400 milliards
et puis les extra budgétaires 13
milliards 3
je fais une première observation c'est
que sensiblement c'est 13 milliards ça
correspond au reste à payer
deuxième observation sur ces 13 3 il y
en a 5 9 qui sont censés être à peu près
identifié c'est à dire des sessions
c'est ce qu'il en est
les recettes du service de santé il
reste donc cette carte à trouver les 7 4
milliards je fais un petit calcul de
quantables à 300 millions près ça
correspond exactement à la marche qui
doit être franchie à partir de 2027
je pense que c'est toujours intéressant
de d'apprécier les ordres de valeur et
c'est ce qui me permet de dire que
peut-être que le budget ne peut pas être
qualifié d'un sincère mais c'est une
incertitude quand même très forte et la
concordance de ces chiffres laisse à
penser que on essaie de renvoyer à des
gens meilleurs le règlement de ces
impasses budgétaires
et aujourd'hui elles sont financées par
une solidarité interministérielle
monsieur le Président vous avez expliqué
que pouvait par définition pratiquement
être quasi inexistante et on est un peu
étonné de spéculer sur des moindres
dépenses à venir alors que nous sommes
en train de faire une loi de
programmation on aurait pu penser au
moins que c'est toi le programmation
tenait compte des dépenses qui avaient
pu être constatées la deuxième
observation et ça vous l'avez pas évoqué
c'est
l'indexation sur les prix à la
consommation je crains et que ce soit
une vision assez optimiste
des coûts en raison des tensions qui
règnent sur l'Europe mais également en
raison du fait que les matériels les
matières premières auxquelles les
équipementsiers font appel risque
d'augmenter plus vite que les prix à la
consommation
troisième observation ça n'a pas été
évoqué c'est la diminution des
provisions pour les Opex alors j'entends
bien qu'on nous explique l'opération
Ukraine
sera comptabiliser à part
pour autant
on sait que depuis de nombreuses années
il faut abonder les opèques ou tout au
moins l'approvision est insuffisante je
note que la diminution de l'approvision
OPEX sur la période c'est quand même 2
milliards quatre qui viennent s'ajouter
aux incertitudes qu'on a évoqué tout à
l'heure sans que l'on puisse toujours
compliquer avec les opaques mais sans
que l'on puisse dire avec certitude que
nous n'aurons pas d'autres
champs d'intervention à l'extérieur
et puis vous avez longuement monsieur le
Président et vous avez eu raison
insister sur l'addition des lois de
programmation en disant que au fond si
on les respectait la marge de manœuvre
pour le reste du budget
sans trouver d'autant atténués vous avez
évoqué la lemmie on nous parle d'une loi
justice on a la loi sur la recherche
mais s'il y avait que ça
si on considère que nous avons quelque
chose qui n'est pas programmé mais qui
est certain qu'elle augmentation de la
dette
et si l'on considère le budget de
l'Éducation nationale à 70 milliards
l'augmentation de la dette la charge de
la dette plus exactement à 60 milliards
c'est plus de 50 % du budget de l'État
qui se trouve complètement figé et donc
imaginez un seul instant que les efforts
qui pourraient être demandés serait
porté sur des budgets de montant
relativement minimes pour assurer une
diminution
de la dette et au fond de notre
désendettement me paraît une vision
assez optimiste tout ceci pour conclure
Madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président en fait que
je ne sais pas si ce budget est
insincert mais il me paraît en tous les
cas et je ne rentre pas sur le fond sur
la programmation simplement la stricte
point de vue budgétaire il me paraît
assez difficile à assumer au regard des
contraintes générales que connaît
actuellement le pays et je voudrais
optimiste et penser quelque chose on
s'améliorer dans les mois à venir mais
je n'ai pas le sentiment que l'on puisse
fonder une perspective à échéance de
2030 sur une amélioration de la
situation internationale et sur une
amélioration de nos finances publiques
merci monsieur le rapporteur pour avis
sur le rapporteur général
merci le Président je remercie le
président du Haut Conseil et je vais
tout de suite rester dans le ton de
cette matinée où je crois que sur un
sujet majeur la défenses nationale
vous avez évoqué le mot d'incertitude je
vais revenir mais je veux dire monsieur
le Président comme vous l'avez fait dans
votre propos introductif et souvent
l'introduction dit l'essentiel le plus
important qui est l'absence de maîtrise
de nos comptes publics et je m'en étonne
d'autant plus que cette démarche
nouvelle a été voulue avec une grande
insistance par la majorité précédente
reconduite
d'un nouveau dispositif afin de
maîtriser nos comptes publics je
m'étonne je regrette pour tout dire je
suis assez en colère contre ce
volte-face
le gouvernement s'exonaire de mettre en
œuvre un dispositif de
maîtrise de nos comptes publics avec des
trajectoires claires sur lesquels il est
il serait encapé de s'engager puisque
finalement pour l'instant il a il est en
sursis à statuer je sais pas exactement
jusque quand sur effectivement la loi de
programmation de nos finances publiques
c'est pas très courageux
au niveau national ça l'est moins encore
me semble-t-il dans le concert européen
et
je pense qu'il faut veiller à ce que ça
ne traduise pas une forme
d'inconséquence budgétaire et d'amnésie
par rapport aux engagements pris il y a
quelques semaines vous avez évoqué ce
mot vous l'avez dit le dictionnaire
riche le mot incertitude alors il a deux
définitions dans ces deux exceptions
j'en ai retenu mais si c'est ça c'est un
peu dans ce cas là ça peut être délicat
puisque
l'incertitude ça peut être qualifiée sa
qualifierait une chose imprévisible
si c'est le cas ou si c'est le cas
il va falloir qu'on se pose tous
une question et monsieur le Président je
le redis s'agissant d'un domaine
régalien ou l'actualité
nous montre à la fois son importance en
termes d'enjeu mais également sur
les questions budgétaires moi je
voudrais simplement
vous demander si cette loi de
programmation n'est finalement
par avant chargé effectivement
d'habiller les incertitudes pensez-vous
pouvoir
lever les doutes qui m'envahissent
et
pensez-vous surtout que
il soit possible à cet instant de
répondre à la contradiction entre la
nécessité de conduire des efforts de
maîtrise de la dépense publique que
chacun appelle de ses vœux est la
poursuite au travers d'un empilement par
exemple de la programmation dans celle
sur la défense nationale de dépenses
nouvelles mal renseignées si j'osais je
dirais est-ce qu'il n'est pas tant
de s'engager là aussi sur la voie de la
sobriété puisque c'est aussi un des
termes très à la mode et très en vogue
aujourd'hui auprès de nos gouvernants
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
merci ma présence avant de céder la
parole à Rachid Thema je voudrais juste
revenir très rapidement sur les propos
qui ont été
fort bien exposé par nos deux
rapporteurs et notamment par Dominique
delay j'avais qui je partage évidemment
la totalité de ce qui a été dit que
l'essentiel de la discussion de se
présente sur ces fameux 13 milliards
dont on a dit exposé très largement
qu'il constitue un budget à la hauteur
de 413 milliards alors qu'en fait ils
sont considérablement différents puisque
c'est 400 plus 13 avec 13 milliards
d'incertitudes ce qui n'est pas une
paille compte tenu de l'augmentation
annuelle du budget prévu jusqu'en 2030
puisqu'on est quasiment à 2 milliards
par an
on avait entendu parler monsieur le
Président vous parliez tout à l'heure de
de d'absence de documentation en tout
cas sur les le reste en plus des 5,8
milliards nous on a entendu parler un
temps de vente de fréquence alors la
vente de fréquence on nous l'avait déjà
faite en 2016 ce que je rappelle que
l'équipe du budget en 2016 devait se
faire avec 800 millions d'euros de vente
de fréquences qui n'ont jamais eu lieu
et avec un effort important de
l'habilité là aussi c'est un sujet quand
même important parce que l'habiter elle
va soumise à rude épreuve avec un
certain nombre de mesures qui vont
intervenir et qui ne vont pas dans le
sens de ce qui était attendu mais en
tout cas s'il devait en plus y avoir un
effort de l'habilité ça serait un peu
plus compliqué encore donc une
incertitude importante qui pèse sur ce
cette question de la défense alors je
reviendrai pas sur l'insécurité ou sur
sur la sincérité ou sur l'incertitude je
pense que c'est plus de la grammaire
comptable qu'autre chose en tout cas il
y a une vraie question à poser et quand
on fait un budget à 400 + 13 on fait pas
un budget à 413 et pour moi aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
communication autour de ça il faut être
plus vigilant et nous le serons parce
que au Sénat on essaie de faire en sorte
que les choses soient les plus sincères
possible et que à la fin de quand il
faut payer l'addition le total soit
conforme à ce qu'on avait eu au départ
donc merci en tout cas pour vos
interventions et je crois que je sais de
la parole à Rachid tu es mal merci
Cédric merci président d'abord remercier
à mon tour également le président du
conseil et à l'ensemble des équipes
comme le mot est incertitude et moi je
partage le choix de ce mot là mais il y
a quand même le on peut se dire que le
monde qui est incertain et qu'il sera de
plus en plus incertain pour le coup est
une certitude donc on a quand même cette
question là devant nous l'autre élément
qui est une certitude c'est que
j'entends le débat sur la loi de
programmation mais on sait très bien que
sur les questions militaires notamment
l'ancien programme entre le moment on
décide d'étudier de lancer de produits
etc c'est du temps long et donc c'est
vrai que la loi de programmation pour le
coup elle se justifie mais une fois
qu'on a dit ça après il faut regarder
l'existant je crois que c'est important
de repartir de là-dessus par rapport à
ce que vous évoquez monsieur le
Président d'abord c'est vrai que il y a
pas de bilan aujourd'hui je rentre pas
sur le fond il n'y a pas de bilan de
l'actuel loi de programmation de terre
parce que je rappelle que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans le cas d'une autre
programmation sanitaire qui va
normalement jusqu'en 2025 et à ce stade
il n'y a pas il y a eu un refus bref
finalement en tout cas il y a pas
d'études sur concrètement ce qu'elle est
je parle bien encore une fois d'un point
de vue que
budgétaire financier il n'y a pas de
valeur
deuxième chose c'est vrai que c'est la
seconde fois qu'on nous fait le coup de
la bosse c'est le deuxième fa qu'on nous
dit bah après on avance pourrissement
puis il y aura une bosse alors ça c'est
bien vu la dernière fois puisque c'était
après effectivement avec son majeure la
protection française et on nous fait le
coup bon il s'avère que là pour le coup
ça parle à notre caution il y aura un
autre président donc c'est quand même
deux sujets qui nous semblent aussi
importants je crois qu'il faut qu'il
faut le dire et c'est vrai que ça ne
peut que nous interroger sur cette façon
surtout quand on y ajoute également ce
qui ce que vous appelez tout à l'heure
les les 13 milliards les 13,3 milliards
dont les 7,4 qui sont aujourd'hui très
peu documentés et puis c'est vrai que on
pourra pas être trop long on peut y
ajouter également dans les termes
d'incertitude vous l'avez dit les restes
à payer
qui sont quand même notables la question
l'inflation pour l'instant n'est que
prévisionnel la question des OPEX c'est
un vrai débat de fond qui est un vrai
débat de fond dire ça ça renvoie à quel
modèle d'armée quelle logique
d'intervention de la France de par le
monde et je veux dire ça c'est un vrai
débat de fond
je l'ai dit les recettes seraient et
puis sur l'Ukraine moi je me félicite
également que le crâne soit pas intégré
enfin à la fin il y a quand même une
question qu'il faut quand même le payer
tout cela donc cela se pose la question
donc c'est vrai que c'est pour ça que
nous considérons que
pour rester que sur la partie budgétaire
mais d'un mot quand même nous
considérons pour certains à la
Commission en plus de faire étrangère
défense et sans armées qu'il n'y a pas
eu le travail préalable
d'analyse de livres blancs et dans notre
histoire de notre pays toutes les
majorités ont su de droite et gauche
c'est n'importe où faire de livres
blancs les livres blancs c'est aussi de
se dire aujourd'hui entre entre
l'annonce de la LP mais aujourd'hui je
rappelle qu'il y a accessoirement la
question de l'Ukraine ça veut dire que
un membre des Nations des Nations Unies
du siège de sécurité avec l'arme
nucléaire décide de partir en guerre je
parle de la Chine on voit ce qui se
passe etc on pourrait prendre plein
d'exemples donc tout cela nécessite un
vrai travail c'est pour ça que ce que
c'est propre cette loi je déborde un peu
sur la commission la nôtre il y a à la
fois pas d'analyse sur là où en sommes
et quels sont les risques pour demain
et il y a aussi je vois et vous le dites
monsieur le Président des questions
d'incertitude également sur la question
budgétaire donc c'est vrai que à ce
stade tout ça ne peut que nous
interroger pour le moins
merci chers collègues je vais prendre
les questions des trois intervenants qui
se sont inscrits et puis je vous
proposerai ce président du Conseil des
finances publiques une réponse globale
donc Vincent Delahaye puis Christian
Billac oui merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président très rapidement
moi je suis pas un grand fan des lois de
programmation d'une façon générale parce
qu'effectivement je trouve que c'est
très bloquant pour pour l'avenir même si
en matière de défense on peut penser
qu'il faut il faut anticiper
effectivement avoir des programmes longs
mais voilà alors moi ce qui m'intéresse
effectivement l'impasse même si 13
milliards on peut penser qu'aujourd'hui
c'est pas grand chose 13 milliards mais
ça reste quand même 13 milliards et
quand on lit effectivement votre rapport
monsieur le Président on voit qu'il y a
des recettes
des recettes du service de santé des
armées donc moi ça m'intéresse de savoir
ce que c'est que ces recettes cette
prévision d'augmentation parce que
j'imagine qu'il y en a déjà aujourd'hui
donc j'imagine qu'il y a les prévisions
d'augmentation de l'attractivité je sais
pas quoi de nos services de santé mais
ça m'intéresserait d'en savoir un petit
peu plus
merci Christian BIAC puis Emmanuel Capu
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président pour votre exposé
alors évidemment avec la modération qui
vous caractérise vous avez
quand même
parler de trajectoire dépassé
d'incertitude
et de nécessaire d'efforts collectifs il
y a 6 mois nous avons voté le
programmation et nous étions nombreux au
sein de la commission des finances à
penser qu'on n'allait pas assez loin
dans le redressement des comptes publics
et là il arrive à Saint-Éloi de
programmation militaire alors pas sur la
même période mais enfin
qui apporte 400 milliards de dépasses de
l'État supplémentaire je rappellerai que
pour redresser les comptes publics de
programmation il était prévu partager
entre la sécurité sociale et les
collectivités territoriales et là on
voit bien dans le graphique qui lui a
été présenté que ces trois points à
rattraper en plus sur la période
2021 3 2027 et j'ai noté aussi que
honoré les crédits identiques jusqu'à en
2027 paraît-il
cela veut-il dire que tous les forts va
porter sur le trois années
2028 2029 et 2030 parce que si on ne
fait pas d'effort jusqu'à 2027 ça veut
dire qu'il faudra tout reporter sur les
trois années suivantes donc vous avez
parlé certitude mais je le présent moi
je la certitude qu'on va dans le mur sur
de prendre pas encore le niveau
d'endettement que nous avons et puis je
crois qu'il faudrait faire un rapport
peut-être sur les côtés à part parce que
ça devait à la mode l'Ukraine le compte
à part la date covid dans la conte à
part maintenant dès qu'il y a une
difficulté on compte à part moi je veux
bien qu'on compte à part mais il faudra
quand même que ce soit les Français qui
rembourse
merci Emmanuel Capu pour terminer merci
un homme la présidente merci monsieur le
Président pour ces explications moi
comme comme mes collègues même si pas
flagrant dans les interventions de mes
collègues je me réjouis de
l'augmentation significative des crédits
qui sont prévus dans cette loi de
programmation militaire face aux enjeux
extrêmement préoccupants en termes de
menaces qui pèse sur la France je me
réjouis aussi que
le Conseil considère que cette
augmentation de moyens est compatible
avec une loi de programmation de finance
publique en tous les cas avec la
trajectoire sinon de rigueur au moins de
maîtrise des comptes qui étaient prévus
dans le projet de loi de programmation
de finance publique au-delà de cette
lecture comptable
des dépenses militaires c'est aussi des
emplois c'est aussi notre base
industrielle et technique de défense
et c'est aussi des investissements donc
et comme le Haut Conseil donne aussi des
éclairages sur les hypothèses de
croissance est-ce que vous avez
des hypothèses des éléments de chiffrage
sur les hypothèses de croissance
induites par cette loi de programmation
militaire
merci chers collègues monsieur le
Président je vous souhaite la parole
pour une réponse globale merci Madame
brise Angel commencer par des éléments
disons factuels puis je terminerai par
de grandes de grands débats que vous
avez soulevé que nous échanges soulève
ce matin d'abord
que si il n'y a pas eu de bilan proposé
en annexe loi de programmation militaire
la Cour des comptes elle fait un bilan
de la LPM 2019-2025 par rapport en effet
que je crois intéressant que j'ai
présenté en son temps qui montrait je
résume les messages quand même
l'exécution plutôt conforme la
programmation des capacités militaires
qui étaient très fortement employés
avec des fragilités et donc
ce qui préfigurait d'un certain nombre
d'orientation qui ont été depuis défini
et nous appelions
des choix pour améliorer des programmes
d'abonnement et la coopération
européenne
je dis ça parce que nous avons fait ce
travail de bilan qui je crois était
utile et d'ailleurs de ce point de vue
là plutôt rassurant enfin qu'on teste le
moins progrès fait même si ils étaient à
compléter pour le reste je ne vais pas
m'engager trop dans ce qui n'est pas ma
compétence je vous laisserai débattre
avec qui de droit de la substance de la
loi de programmation de son contenu de
sa pertinence
mon point de vue bien particuliers
encore une fois si la conformité entre
cette loi de programmation et la
programmation de finances publiques je
vais à partir de là ajouter un certain
nombre d'éléments d'abord que se
passerait-il si l'inflation était
sous-estimée le projet militaire a été
construit en effet avec les mêmes
prévisions d'inflation que celle du
projet qui est quand même la moindre des
choses or la prévision d'inflation du
gouvernement pour 2023 et désormais un
peu basse comme son conseil avait relevé
dans son avis sur le projet de loi
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale qui
portait la forme des retraites selon le
consensus économistes aujourd'hui
l'inflation pour 2003 atteindrait 4,9%
contre 4,2 pour la prévision du
gouvernement par ailleurs le Conseil
dans son avis relatif au plfp Revel les
incertitudes du retour des prix à partir
206 avec un niveau compatible à celui de
la cible de la Banque centrale
européenne donc bon incontestablement me
semble-t-il prévisions qui est un peu
optimiste quand même pour 2023 et il y a
des incertitudes pour la période qui
vient on constate quand même c'était dit
par plusieurs dirigeants d'organisations
internationales y compris certains jours
que il résistance de l'inflation et de
l'inflation coeur qui doivent nous faire
réfléchir les uns et autres il est donc
possible que l'inflation à partir de
laquelle a été construit le lot de
programmation militaire soit
sous-évaluée encore une fois pas de
manière insère parce que il y a aussi
des beaucoup d'incertitudes sur l'avenir
ce qui est à mon sens sous-évalué d'ores
et déjà c'est la prévision 2023 dans ce
cas ce surplus d'inflexion pourrait
susciter un ajustement des crédits
budgétaires en Europe pour assurer le
respect des rotations stratégiques du
projet de programmation militaire il est
à noter que celui-ci prévoit
explicitement des mesures d'ajustements
mais seulement en cas de hausse du prix
des carburants opérationnels il peut y
avoir d'autres ajustements dans un
contexte d'inflation dynamique il y a
une question qui se pose sous-jacente ou
pas poser directement mais nous la
sommes posés quid de la trajectoire de
la programmation militaire en volume le
projet programme solidaire prévoit une
augmentation importante des crédits de
la mission défense en valeur
6,3% par an en moyenne entre 2023 et 27
je maintiens 2023-2027 parce que c'est
notre mandat 2027 2030 c'est la marche
suivante c'est dépenses restent
dynamiques en volume le projet de
programmation militaire était construit
à partir des mêmes prévisions
d'inflation juridiques que celle du
projet finance publique et en prenant en
compte ces prévisions d'inflation les
crédits de la mission défense augmentera
en volume de plus de 4% par an entre
2023 2027 avec une inflation plus
dynamique là-haut serait moindre mais il
y a quand même une place pour une
augmentation de la dépense de défense
mais évidemment tout ça devrait être
ajusté avec le temps avec les évolutions
de l'inflation pour ce qui est des OPEX
elles ont été sur exécutées ces
dernières années mais il y a une baisse
de la provision de 1 milliard d'euros à
0 milliard d'euros qui est justifié
notamment il s'agit pas de l'Ukraine je
compte à part je n'interviens pas mais
une forme de désengagement ou d'un
moindre engagement en Afrique je pense
notamment l'opération barkhane sur la
BITD c'est à dire la base industrielle
technologique de défense et aussi les
prisons de croissance alors nous n'avons
pas fait de prison de croissance quand
j'ai présenté ce même avis commission de
ou même commission à l'Assemblée
nationale la question m'a été posée sur
un multiplicateur keynésien il peut être
localisé nous n'avons pas le sentiment
que globalement ça induit un surcroît de
croissance potentielle mais bien sûr
nous connaissons la base industrielle
nous connaissons les emplois qui sont
induits nous voyons aussi les régions
qui sont touchées mais je parle en
termes de croissance potentielle globale
et sur le moyen terme la réponse est
plutôt non il y a pas de surcroît de
croissance pour ce qui est de de la base
industrielle elle-même elle n'est pas
dans le champ du hcfp
la capacité toutefois de celle-ci à
répondre aux besoins reste entouré
d'incertitude mais ne vont pas
d'expertise particulière en la matière
pour ce qui est des recettes du service
de santé sur des contributions des
armées à l'offre de soins c'est
récurrent
les recettes sur le service de santé
sont environ 0,5 milliards d'euros par
an
ça ne nous paraît pas inatteignable
c'est pour ça que nous avons dit que les
5,9 milliards d'euros
offrait ce que vous voulez mais notre
sentiment doux c'est que cela sont quand
même grosso modo documentés
monsieur le rapporteur spécial tapas ou
à financer qui eux sont entourés
incontestablement d'incertitude nous le
disons à notre sens c'est-à-dire que
nous n'avons pas la documentation
précise qui correspond aux recettes au
moindre dépense qui permettrait
d'arriver à se financement ce qui
m'amène au dos des bas globaux avec
lesquels je veux conclure qui sont ceux
que j'avais introduit incertitude un
sincérité monsieur le rapporteur général
pour nous c'est pas de la grammaire
comptable c'est de la sémantique quand
même qui a son importance et
d'économique et aussi politique là
sincérité supposerait qu'il y a un désir
de tromper le Parlement et qu'on sache
déjà que toutes les hypothèses sur
lequel a été construit le projet de
programmation militaire sont
inatteignables chez de façon volontaire
ou par un irréalisme assum c'est pas ce
que nous pensons et c'est la raison pour
laquelle pour ma part je suis
extrêmement économe du moins sincérité
j'ai trop de respect pour le politique
que j'ai d'ailleurs été dans le passé
pour penser qu'il est facilement un
sincère il peut lui arriver d'être
volontariste ça c'est un autre terme que
le au Conseil utilise parfois là je
parle bien d'incertitude parce que vous
avez évoqué les incertitudes
internationales les uns et les autres
elles sont incontestables donc forcément
il y a des adaptations qui peuvent être
il y a les incertitudes sur l'inflation
et elle pèse sur la suite un
contestablement également et enfin les
incertitudes sur le financement de 7,4
milliards d'euros qui font le gap entre
les 400 + 5,9 et les 413,3
il est légitime de se poser des
questions et je pense que ce sera pas
une légitime que vous les posiez à qui
de droit pendant l'examen du projet de
loi de programmation militaire nous nous
n'avons pas la réponse aujourd'hui je
dis que nous n'avons pas la réponse
parce que nous l'avons demandé le Haut
Conseil procède par sa propre expertise
d'abord mais il le fait à partir d'un
questionnaire qui l'adresse aux
administration et d'auditions que nous
avons faites des administrations
approfondies et là dessus nous n'avons
pas eu les chiffres les détails
comparables à ce que nous avons sur le
5,9 voilà pourquoi nous disons que les
uns sont documentés globalement
atteignables et les autres sont
incertains voilà la différence enfin
reste le grand débat
pour le coup et la mission du Haut
Conseil et
celle de la Cour des comptes aussi qui
est celui de la maîtrise de nos comptes
publics
une assemblée
pluraliste par définition
s'exprime des choix de démocratiques
différents et évidemment selon qu'on
soit de droite de gauche du centre ou
d'ailleurs la façon de réduire les
déficits publics ou la dette la
conception qu'on en a n'est pas la même
je ne l'ignore pas complètement mais je
veux quand même attirer votre attention
sur le fait que c'est un impératif
auquel personne personne ne peut se
soustraire et je le redis nous sommes
confrontés à une situation qui est très
particulière la France est un pays qui
aujourd'hui est un des pays les plus
endettés de la zone euro
111% du PIB ça n'était pas le cas au
moment du lancement de la zone euro
c'est un pays de surcroît dont la
dynamique de désendettement est quasi
nulle si vous regardez le droit de
programmation de finances publiques on
est à 111% aujourd'hui on sera encore à
111% en 2027 on serait juste à 3% en
2027 ça veut dire que nous sommes dans
une logique qui maintenant te décrochage
ou de divergence au moins avec nos
partenaires de la zone euro nous avons
58% de dépenses publiques dans le PIB ce
qui en soi n'est pas l'indicateur
suffisant sauf qu'il faut se rapporter à
la qualité de la dépense à ce qu'on a le
sentiment toujours que nos concitoyens
sont satisfaits de l'éducation nationale
de la santé des différents services
publics donc il faut toujours adapter la
qualité à la quantité tout de même et
nous sommes dans cette situation
maintenant ou le service de la dette
puisque nous sommes plus en taux
d'intérêt négatif puisque les taux
d'intérêt augmenter à nouveau puisqu'il
y a de l'inflation et des obligations
indexées sur l'inflation le service de
la dette étant passe de rattraper le
budget de la défense comme le budget
voire de le dépasser comme le deuxième
budget de l'État et par expérience vous
savez les uns et les autres que c'est
vraiment la dépense plus que la moins
productive qui soit tout heureux que
vous allez consacrer au remboursement de
la dette est un euro en moins pour notre
défense pour notre sécurité intérieure
pour
nos hôpitaux pour la justice enfin bref
pour toutes les préférences que chacun
peut exprimer et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut réduire notre dette
c'est ce qui nous permette de retrouver
de la marge de manœuvre pour préparer
l'avenir pour investir dans les
différents domaines qui sont les nôtres
voilà pourquoi je pense qu'on ne peut
pas se dérober devant cette question
aujourd'hui qui est une question grave
pour pour la nation je crois et qui
mérite un grand débat et qui mérite
aussi des mesures c'est la raison pour
laquelle je le redis la revue de
dépenses publiques qui maintenant
devrait s'engager est un exercice
extrêmement important qui en fait n'a
jamais été tenté dans notre pays et dont
nous avons un besoin impératif et je
vous redis que la Cour des comptes que
je préside par ailleurs si on gâchera
pour sa part et prête à contribuer à
l'exercice global parce que ça nous
semble vraiment très très important nous
ne pouvons pas rester dans cette
situation donc je termine madame la
Présidente parce que je sais que vous
avez un horaire je redis un que nous
avons besoin d'une loi de programmation
de finances publiques
impératif deux que je souhaite que
celle-ci soit crédible et ambitieuse
donc soit un peu plus ambitieuse que le
projet qui était proposé en septembre
dernier et que 3 la revue de dépenses
publiques ne nous permettent de délivrer
les efforts collectifs dont le pays a
besoin
il en a besoin et c'est ce qui lui
permettra de rester crédible et fort
dans l'euro qui est notre choix
collectif
merci monsieur le Premier Président pour
ces informations et ses appréciations je
vous propose de rester nos côtés pour
poursuivre l'ordre du jour de la
commission des finances je remercie le
président Perrin ainsi que l'ensemble
des membres de la commission des
affaires étrangères pour ces 30 juin à
nous ce matin je vais suspendre quelques
minutes pour nourrir organiser et
poursuivre l'ordre du jour merci à
toutes et tous